das ist das schloss von versailles
hunderte angestellte extravagante feste
hallen aus gold und ein riesiger park
mit eigenen kanälen ein leben in luxus
und reichtum das nur den obersten 0,001
prozent der gesellschaft vorbehalten war
und vielleicht bald auch dir oder mir
nehmen wir mal an buddhisten und hindus
haben recht und so etwas ähnliches wie
inka nationen gibt es wirklich das heißt
nachdem du stirbst wirst du
wiedergeboren zu einer anderen zeit und
an einem anderen ort und zu deinem glück
kannst du dir sogar aussuchen wohin ist
dich in deinem neuen leben verschlagen
soll in unseren gedanken experiment hast
du zwei möglichkeiten erstens du wirst
wieder geboren als kind einer normalen
mittelständischen familie im jahr 2000
oder option 2 du wirst wieder geboren im
jahr 1710 als der französische
thronfolger ludwig der fünfzehnte wofür
entscheidest du dich
[Musik]
als thronfolger kannst du dich von einer
normalen wohnung verabschieden denn ab
jetzt gehört dir ein ganzer palast neben
einem zimmer nur für deine hunde und
einem weiteren zimmer nur für deine
uhren stehen knapp 2000 bedienstete nur
in den küchen des palastes bereit
jetzt bist du am obersten ende der
nahrungskette wortwörtlich jeder wunsch
wird dir von deinen lippen abgelesen die
muss nie wieder langweilig sein du
veranstaltet gigantische feste tage lang
geld ist kein problem geht es dann zum
ernst des lebens zurück dann stehen hier
die besten bildungsmöglichkeiten des
landes zur verfügung
du hast die möglichkeit dich von den
klügsten köpfen des 18 jahrhunderts
unterrichten zu lassen
russo diderot oder wollte er mit einem
fingerschnipsen sitzen ein paar der
größten philosophen aller zeiten in
deinem palast und erklären dir die welt
ist es dann zeit deinen thron anzutreten
hast du die macht und ressourcen um die
welt zu verändern
heutzutage besitzt wahrscheinlich kein
mensch weltweit die macht die du jetzt
hast du reagierst schließlich frankreich
kolonialmacht und als der größten
europäischen könig reise politisch sieht
das für dich auch relativ entspannt aus
das achtzehnte jahrhundert hatte zwar
ein zwei kleine kriege jahr verlierst
kanada als kolonie aber sonst hätte ich
nichts davon ab ob es zu faulenzen oder
moment mal da war doch irgendwas
[Musik]
ok also spätestens 1789 wird sich die
welt für dich ein kleines bisschen
verändern denn dein luxus hat einen
preis der auf den schultern von armen
bauern getragen wird
aber vielleicht hast du ja glück denn
damit du die französische revolution
überhaupt erlebst musst du nämlich erst
einmal 79 jahre alt werden und könig
ludwig der fünfzehnte hat gerade mal von
1710 bis 1774 überlebt denn brocken
tuberkulose oder andere plagen machen
vor einem blauen blut nicht halt und das
gesundheitswesen im 18 jahrhundert ist
mehr sagen wir mal ausbaufähig ok dafür
hattest du aber jahrzehnte voller saus
und braus oder leider wirst du selbst
als zukünftiger könig oder als königin
nicht so viele freiheiten haben wie
teilweise heutzutage besonders als frau
sieht das achtzehnte jahrhundert nicht
so rosig für dich aus patriarchale
strukturen zwangsheirat mit deinen art
lieben verwandten dein leben ist
komplett durchgeplant so dass nur für
den erhalt des stammbaums sorgt hinzu
kommt dass hunderttausende bauern am
existenzminimum leben damit du mit
goldenen besteck essen kannst sollen die
bauern halt kuchen essen wenn sie kein
boot haben oder wie war das nochmal
na ja da hat selbst das leckerste
festessen einen faden beigeschmack
ok so wie sich das jetzt anhört ist das
also eine ziemlich einfache entscheidung
viele dieser probleme sind gelöst wenn
du dich für die gegenwart entscheidest
du bist da mit großer wahrscheinlichkeit
ein ganz normaler mensch ohne reichtum
und macht aber dafür profitierst du von
modernster medizin und hat die freiheit
dich selbst zu verwirklichen
du kannst überall hinreisen wo du willst
du bist mobiler und flexibler als eine
der mächtigsten personen vor gerade mal
300 jahren an dieser stelle dürfen wir
auch nicht den technischen fortschritt
vergessen auf schloss versailles läuft
kein netflix du kannst nicht mal eben
ein smartphone schicken während du auf
die kutsche wartest und das plumpsklo
brauchen wir gar nicht erst gegen ein
modernes bad antreten zu lassen
diesen fortschritt würdest du im 18
jahrhundert aber natürlich nicht
wirklich vermissen denn diese zeit ist
damit eine neue realität schließlich
vermissen wir jetzt gerade ja auch nicht
die technologien aus der zukunft
trotzdem stehen wir in der gegenwart auf
den schultern von hunderten jahren an
fortschritt die unsere realität um
einiges einfacher machen als noch vor
300 jahren
dieser fortschritt hat aber auch seinen
preis klimawandel
massenvernichtungswaffen und die
ausbeutung günstiger arbeitskräfte ganz
so dramatisch wie im feudalismus ist das
natürlich nicht
trotzdem werden auch in der gegenwart
große opfer für den konsum der oberen
paar prozent gebracht und weltweit
gesehen sind wir die oberen paar prozent
wir sind die könige des
einundzwanzigsten jahrhunderts wie wurde
deine antwort zum beispiel aussehen wenn
du heute überall auf der ganzen welt
geboren werden konntest
je nach seinem geburtsort hast du auch
in der gegenwart so gut wie keine
mobilität und leidet unter armut und
krieg profitiert nicht vom fortschritt
der menschheit und passt so gut wie
keine möglichkeit dein schicksal selbst
zu gestalten und das kann ja auch
passieren wenn du in deutschland geboren
wurdest als französischer könig hast du
das geld und die macht um das achtzehnte
jahrhundert zu einem fairen ort zu
machen
chancengleichheit für alle die
industrialisierung steht noch vor der
tür
du könntest den weg ebnen für eine
nachhaltige zukunft und so maßgeblich
die weltgeschichte verändern
das setzt natürlich voraus dass
überhaupt das interesse entwickelt
zumindest frankreich zu einem besseren
ort zu machen
denn du würdest die gleiche bildung
sozialisierung und politisierung wie ein
vergleichbarer monarch zu dieser zeit
bekommen und da stehen chancengleichheit
fairness und ethik nicht gerade ganz
oben auf der agenda und realistisch
gesehen wird es ganz schön hart sein
jahrhundertealte machtstrukturen einfach
so umzuwerfen
denn allein in frankreich gibt es neben
dir genug leute die von den feudalen
strukturen profitieren und überhaupt
kein interesse haben ihre privilegien zu
verlieren
auch andere königreiche werden nicht
sehr begeistert sein wenn du das
traditionelle system um wirst du so
wurden schon kriege wegen kleineren
problemen angefangen und vielleicht
kommst du ja gar nicht so weit
vielleicht steigt der deine macht sogar
zu kopf du wirst nicht der erste könig
der verrückt wird könig karl der sechste
dachte zeit seines lebens das er aus
glas wäre und hat deswegen tagelang
still gesessen um nicht kaputt zu gehen
lassen wir das materielle das
gesellschaftliche und das politische mal
außen vor
das lebenswerteste leben ist dass in dem
die unglücklichsten bist und was glück
bedeutet das muss jeder für sich selbst
entscheiden
falls ihr euch für die wissenschaft
hinter glück interessiert dann schaut
euch gerne mal dieses video von mir zu
diesem thema haben orientieren wir uns
an den menschenrechten dann kann man ein
paar fundamentalen voraussetzungen für
ein glückliches leben definieren
platonische und nicht platonische
beziehungen zu verschiedenen menschen
komfort also eine gute versorgung an
sicherheit und nahrung und anerkennung
und respekt durch mitmenschen dieses
glück kannst du sowohl als thronfolger
aber auch als normaler bürger erreichen
mit einem kleinen unterschied in der
gegenwart braucht es für deine
sicherheit und komfort arbeit und geld
müssen zwei dinge um die sich ein
thronfolger keine gedanken machen muss
in der gegenwart lebst du in der
leistungsgesellschaft schon früh musst
du dich entscheiden welchen bildungsweg
du einschläfst um später vielleicht mal
eine familie ernähren zu können
dabei stehen die unfassbar viele
möglichkeiten zur verfügung für viele
menschen ist das fluch und segen
zugleich
unsere eigene identität und rolle in der
gesellschaft zu finden ist vielleicht so
schwierig wie noch nie zuvor in der
geschichte der menschheit
what a life crisis midlife crisis
altersarmut für viele menschen sorgt die
leistungsgesellschaft für enormen druck
als thronfolger sind eine
grundbedürfnisse für dein ganzes leben
befriedigt und manch einer ist
vielleicht auch ganz froh dass das
eigene leben im 18 jahrhundert nach
einem gewissen plan verläuft
vielleicht brauchen wir aber auch das
moderne streben nach glück um uns
glücklich zu fühlen wenn du von
vorneherein alles besitzt was du jemals
besitzen kannst wird man dann nicht
unglücklich ok jetzt würde mich mal eure
meinung interessieren für welches leben
würdet ihr euch entscheiden schreibt mir
gerne unten in den kommentaren lasst uns
zusammen darüber diskutieren
wenn ihr kein kommen das video verpassen
wollt dann abonniert gerne den kanal
dass es kostenlos ansonsten wie immer
vielen dank fürs zuschauen bis zum
nächsten mal bleibt neugierig euer könig
cedrick der fünf dach was sage ich da
patrick reicht